[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
muchas veces me sorprendo pensando
obsesivamente en el dinero y no es una
buena sensación porque o bien tengo
miedo de perder el dinero que ya tengo o
sino por otro lado tengo una sensación
de ansiedad de querer ganar más que el
que ya tengo robert kiyosaki dijo una
vez me siento contento cuando entra
dinero a mi bolsillo y me siento triste
cuando sale de él esa es mi relación con
el dinero pero si preguntamos a un
familiar oa un amigo cómo es tu relación
con el dinero tenés problemas con el
dinero es importante para ti la posible
respuesta solemne es lo importante es la
salud
otra posible respuesta esta vez desde la
sabiduría popular es el dinero muy bien
y una respuesta pensada es lo importante
no es el dinero sino lo que hace es con
él qué interesante parece que yo soy el
único que tiene problemas con el dinero
todo lo demás lo tienen resuelto lo
importante
es que el dinero está relacionado con la
posesión alejandro jodorowsky dijo que
nuestro cerebro más primitivo el
reptiliano es el que controla el
territorio controla la comida controla
la descendencia y también controla el
dinero porque tiene que ver justamente
con la posesión la posesión del dinero y
el deseo de incrementar nuestra riqueza
arrancó mucho antes de que existiera el
dinero arrancó cuando se intercambiaban
productos por productos es decir el
trueque pero el trueque es muy incómodo
pronto tendría que aparecer algo
distinto el rey al día test de lidia
1300 años antes de cristo acuñó la
primera moneda de la historia se llamó
el león de lidia y resolvió un gran
problema para la sociedad a la distancia
también me resolvió a mí un problema
porque yo me crié en el campo y si
hubiera tenido que salir a divertirme y
no hubiera dinero hubiera tenido que
decir de mamá
quiero ir al cine voy a pagar con el
ternero
mi mamá siempre presente hubiera dicho
hijo cuidado que hace frío humano está
bien pago con la oveja
lo importante
es no hacernos tanto el harakiri y
ponerle todos nuestros problemas al
dinero porque el dinero sí que tiene
problemas intrínsecos el primer problema
y más importante es que su producción es
centralizada la producción centralizada
desde la antigüedad sólo podía ser
realizada por reinos con mucho poder de
industria para acuñar las monedas
metálicas y también con mucha capacidad
militar porque había que forzar a las
personas a que usen esa moneda y
disuadir a falsificadores para que no
operen en el territorio
pensemos desde otro punto de vista la
centralización
el juego de monopoly para que funcione
tiene al principio una regla muy
importante que a veces la pasamos por
alto y simplemente si dios adelante esa
regla dice que a cada participante
equitativamente se le va a dar 1500
pesos eso no ocurre en la vida real
por otro lado nuestras penurias no
terminan ahí porque se nos ha enseñado
desde muy chiquititos que compramos
cosas con dinero ese es un enorme error
de enseñanza financiera porque lo
primero que ocurre cuando empezamos a
trabajar nosotros damos nuestro trabajo
y ahí nos dan dinero cuando producimos
un producto lo primero que ocurre es que
damos el producto y ahí obtenemos el
dinero es lo que yo llamo comprar el
dinero con nuestros productos pero eso
es hasta ahora
porque ahora hay una nueva tecnología
que permite que el dinero no se produzca
en forma centralizada que permite que
tengamos una relación más sana con el
dinero y que además no pueda ser
manipulado en sus valores de emisión
produciendo devaluaciones esa tecnología
se llama bloqueo la bloqueen tuvo un
sistema precursor que es el sistema de
descarga de archivos descentralizado ese
sistema lo conocemos como el sistema de
descarga de películas por ejemplo que se
llama torrent sobre este tipo de redes
se basó el sistema de bloques y le
agregó el procesamiento distribuido en
cada nodo de la bloquera que es una
computadora hay un sistema un programa
igual a todos los demás y también tiene
todo el registro de todas las
operaciones que ocurren en la red y
replicadas clonadas es un sistema
extremadamente confiable porque no puede
ser atacado porque no está controlado
por ningún gobierno por ningún estado y
por ningún grupo pequeño de personas
la cripto moneda
más famosa basada en bloque es bitcoin y
en diez años pasó de valer unos pocos
centavos de dólar a valer seis mil
quinientos dólares por unidad del día de
hoy y eso es por la enorme confianza que
está teniendo las distintas sociedades
del mundo en este tipo de monedas pagar
con una cripto moneda es muy sencillo se
hace de una manera similar a una
billetera virtual que ya conocemos
solamente hay que escanear el código qr
de nuestro destinatario ponemos el valor
y enviamos es tan sencillo como eso y
tan barato como eso pero la bloque no
tiene solamente disrupción en el campo
del dinero también nos permite hacer
registros indelebles que no pueden ser
borrados distribuidos en todas esas
computadoras y no pueden ocurrir
pérdidas de archivos se pueden hacer
registros de propiedades se pueden hacer
registros de automotores controles de
cadenas de frío controles de
medicamentos la block chen está
cambiando la manera en que operamos en
el mundo y finalmente dos
características brillantes de las cripto
monedas
la primera es el techo de emisión las
criptas monedas tienen un límite que no
puede ser sobrepasado y también tienen
una segunda característica muy
importante el ritmo de producción de las
cripto monedas es siempre el mismo
siempre estable y son pequeñas
cantidades que ocurren en un en cada
intervalo de tiempo no es posible
alterar el valor de la moneda de
evaluando la con grandes emisiones de
dinero la block chen nos permite volver
a tomar el control del dinero y podemos
usarla no es difícil si queremos
reclamar nuestros derechos con respecto
al dinero
depende de nosotros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]